It isn’t easy to work for The SCP Foundation.
Not only is the job dangerous - you could be
eaten by a giant, immortal lizard
or turned into organic furniture
inside the world’s scariest living room - but it’s
also insanely complicated. How do you make sense
of the nonsensical? What’s the definition
of strange when your career is securing,
containing, and protecting anomalous objects
and entities? This brings us to SCP - 001.
Rather than a single object, location, or
being, SCP - 001 is a cluster of over 30
different proposals for potential candidates for
the prestigious 001 spot. Some believe there’s a
true 001 hidden in this group and the rest are
decoys, others think that these are all just
SCPs catalogued prior to the introduction
of the current classification system.
Some even think that all of the proposals
have a valid claim to the SCP - 001 throne.
We’re not here to make a final judgement, instead,
we’re going to take you on a lightning-round crash
course through 31 of the SCP - 001 proposals. If
you’d like a more in-depth take on any of
these SCPs, let us know in the comments,
but for now, there’s no more time to
waste. After all, we’ve got a lot to cover.
Let’s go.
Number 31: The Sheaf of Papers. This seemingly
innocent stack of paper is actually one of the
most mysterious and feared items under
the Foundation’s lock and key. While
it appears to be a simple confidential
report, every time the papers are read,
it details the appearance of a new SCP that will
inevitably be discovered soon after. The question
is whether the sheaf of papers is warning us
about these entities, or creating them itself.
Number 30: The Prototype. This account details
the capture of an incredibly strange cycloptic
creature that emits massive amounts of
radiation and can create microsingularities.
The writing of this creature’s file is
so basic, unformatted, and unredacted
that it’s clear that the being was one of the
earlier creatures secured by the organization.
Interestingly, it was during the capture
of this creature that Dr. Keter was killed,
inspiring the creation of the
infamous Keter Class in his honor.
Number 29: The Gate Guardian. This huge,
multi-winged, sword-wielding Biblical energy-being
may have been the impetus for the founding of the
SCP Foundation. This being remains largely static,
guarding the intersection of the Tigris
and Euphrates rivers. Its flaming sword,
which is believed to be as hot as the sun,
can cleave any aggressor out of existence at
the atomic level. When the Founder of the SCP
Foundation first encountered the Gate Guardian,
they heard one word echoing through their
mind: PREPARE. And the rest is history.
Number 28: The Lock. This onyx gemstone and
the incredibly complex lock attached to it
are still a mystery. To this day,
all attempts to open have failed.
Personally, we think that’s
probably for the best...
Number 27: The Factory. As the name suggests,
this SCP is literally a factory founded by a
pagan and a devil worshipper. While it’s believed
that the factory could create just about anything,
its specialty was creating a number of the
SCPs we know and fear today. Pre-Foundation
Forces were able to disable the factory, but
not without sustaining their own heavy losses.
Number 26: The Spiral Path. This is a normal
appearing gravel pathway that, when travelled
clockwise, appears completely normal. However,
when travelled counter-clockwise, the path goes
uphill forever, in defiance of all laws of
physics. This simple anomaly opened a Pandora’s
box of rampant anomaly creation - leading to
a number of the deadly SCPs we know today.
Number 25: The Legacy. This SCP is a
collection of seemingly random objects,
including a diary from a person
claiming to be from another reality,
attempting to halt a trans-dimensional corruption
that they themselves created. The diary claims
to have a solution to this Corruption,
but the solution has not yet been found.
Number 24: The Database. In one of the strangest
twists on the format, this SCP is actually the
various authors of the SCP Wiki, who are somehow
leaking top-secret information to the public.
Number 23: The Foundation. This
SCP, first discovered by the FBI,
is an anomalous high school building that
experiences shifting internal geometry
and sometimes manifests hostile humanoids within.
Number 22: Thirty-Six. One of the rare benevolent
SCPs, the thirty-six are humans with a truly
remarkable ability - they can dampen or even
neutralize any SCP they come into contact with.
Though it’s implied that the thirty-six may have
the power to save the world, every time one of
them dies, a supernatural calamity occurs,
often leaving hundreds of innocents dead.
Number 21: Keter Duty. This refers to a
containment facility largely filled with
Keter-class SCPs, whose presence around each other
creates a kind of mutually-assured cancellation.
If one of these SCPs breaches containment,
that’s bad news. But if all of them do,
it’ll produce a bubble of reality
distortion that will fundamentally
alter reality as we know it. For all we
know, it may have even happened already...
Number 20: Ouroboros. This is a proposal that’s
formed of four sub-proposals. Remember what
we said about complicated? These sub-proposals
include The Children - nine anomalous kids who
emit radiation and have destructive potential when
together. The Broken God - aka Mekhane, The god of
metal, intelligence, and machines. Atonement - A
researcher turned into a humanoid singularity with
the power to destroy whole realities. And The Way
It Ends - which isn’t technically an SCP, but the
tales of the Chaos Insurgency’s quest to eliminate
all the members of the Foundation’s O5 Council.
Number 19: A Record. This is an SCP
File slot that is itself an SCP.
Whatever is written in this slot becomes
true, and one ambitious researcher attempted
to use this power to make herself
into a kind of all-powerful God.
Number 18: Past and Future. These
SCPs are a collection of powerful
entities that despise humanity, and
are apparently the source of all
anomalous phenomena - even making already
dangerous SCPs deadlier than before.
Much like in The Database, those pesky SCP Wiki
writers may have something to do with this...
Number 17: The Consensus. This SCP refers to a
reality restructuring event caused by an occult
war in a previous reality. That’s right -
this SCP already won, and we’re living in
its new reality. The only people who remember the
world as it once was are thirteen people who now
form the O5 council. And not all of them are
telling the truth about what they know...
Number 16: When Day Breaks. This proposal details
a potentially world-ending SCP phenomenon, wherein
the sun becomes hostile and begins to melt all
living beings into a living wax-like substance.
Number 15: God’s Blind Spot. This is an
anomalous area referred to as Facility T,
in which nobody can die. This anomaly dates
back to the Biblical age of Moses, and is
believed to have originated from the literal
blessing of the Abrahamic God. It’s through
a covenant with this God that the Foundation is
able to make limited use of this death free area.
Number 14: Normalcy. Ever wondered what the
Foundation’s definition of “anomalous” is,
exactly? It all comes from this proposal
- which is a document shared among the O5
council that gives solid definitions
to the fundamental laws of reality.
If something breaks these laws, that’s an anomaly,
and it then becomes the Foundation’s business.
Number 13: The World At Large. As the title
suggests, this SCP is our home planet Earth
and its ability to support life.
It’s believed that these qualities
were planted on Earth in our reality
by another dimension’s SCP Foundation
hoping to continue human life after some
terrible calamity in its own dimension.
Number 12: Dead Men. This SCP was an 84 year
old man whose body, when damaged and mutilated,
can affect the very processes of human
death at large. Before his own death,
he was used as a dangerous pawn in a civil
war between O5 Command and the SCP Foundation
Ethics Committee. Yeah, we were surprised
to hear they had an ethics committee too.
Number 11: The World’s Gone Beautiful. This
SCP describes an anomalous event that will
take place just before the apocalypse,
in which flowers will grow all over the
world and everyone will be briefly at peace
before their destruction 24 hours later.
Number 10: The Scarlet King. This is an
extremely powerful, extremely malevolent,
extremely extra-dimensional being. Its
worshippers attempted to summon him in
the ritual that created SCP - 231, and
it’s believed that he will finally enter
our reality after the death of SCP - 231 - 7.
You better hope you’re already dead by then.
Number 9: A Simple Toymaker, aka Dr.
Wondertainment. This is a reality bender who
appears to be a normal human male, but has
the ability to create other anomalous objects
- a number of which are now catalogued SCPs.
Number 8: Story of Your Life. This is another
anomalous document that has the ability to warp
reality, but only when the writing contained
within conforms to narrative structure.
Number 7: A Good Boy. This is another
anomalous entity created accidentally
by the Foundation itself. A neural network was
fed information on other anomalous entities
in order to help the Foundation come up with
better containment and neutralization procedures.
Problem was, the computer got way, way
too eager with the neutralization part...
Number 6: Project Palisade. This is another
anomaly created by the Foundation, this time
to combat a potentially reality-destroying entity
known as The Worm. The Foundation created a number
of alternate realities as shields, but it’s
possible that this just made The Worm stronger.
Number 5: O5 - 13. The final member
of the O5 council who, ironically,
may not even be anomalous. However,
seeing as all the other members of the
O5 council are anomalous, O5 - 13’s lack
of anomalous properties is, therefore,
anomalous. Like we told you
earlier, it’s complicated.
Number 4: Fishook. This is less an actual SCP,
and more about the difficult process
of ascertaining the true 001 - if such
a thing is possible. The very concept of SCP
- 001 is, to some degree, an anomalous idea.
Number 3: The Sky Above the Port. Another
particularly bizarre SCP regarding the permanent
threat of a ZK-Class Reality Failure. How is
such a calamitous event prevented? By keeping a
strange entity in a cave eternally entertained.
The current proposed solution is keeping the
entity entertained by allowing it to read its
own eternally recursive Foundation file entry.
Number 2: The Solution. Another one of the most
powerful anomalous items in the Foundation’s
control, the Solution is a machine designed
with the capability of fully collapsing reality
in the event of an end-of-the-world SCP
containment breach. And then, fully rebuilding
reality to suit a given narrative. However,
things took a cosmically dangerous turn when
the machine began to act on its own. When
the Foundation tried to reboot the machine,
it broke, and recreated reality with incomplete
data. This is the world we exist in now,
with no knowledge of what came before, and how
it differed from the world we experience today.
Finally, Number 1: The Tindalos Trinity. Put
very simply, the Tindalos Trinity represents
three timelines that converge and feed back in on
themselves. Even trying to summarize this one is
near-impossible, as its strangeness and complexity
resists all reduction. You can hunt down the
Tindalos Trinity yourself and hope to unpack
its secrets, but don’t say we didn’t warn you.
So, that’s SCP - 001, all 31 potential
proposals. Is it one of them, all of them,
or even none of them? Perhaps that’s a question
best left up to the Foundation. Or maybe the
simple answer is that you’re just not meant
to know - we’re talking about information so
privileged here that it’s protected by a Memetic
Kill Agent that’ll quite literally make you
drop dead if you view the files without proper
authorization. You do have proper authorization,
right? Quick… click on one of these other
videos instead! Before you’re detected!